you said you were
driving about three hours or so to go
get a truck and i just want to know how
that went did you buy it and how's that
truck working out for you is it hauling
them cows around as well as it needs to
be
either way i'd love to hear from you
best of luck
against edson barboza and that's a real
dude right yeah that's a real guy he's
in man that guy's in
what'd you get
a ford f-350 oh there's a 91.
bro it's it's like a [ __ ] little
redneck paradise bro it's like it has no
key on it it's like a push start and
then yeah it's like he rigged up all the
wires he rigged up a push start in brake
lights yeah it's a push start and you
have to use a screwdriver to flip a
switch well on the way home what i
didn't know on the back of the push
start is like
it he literally rigged it up like on the
spot well if you touch the positive and
the negative i let it hit the clutch and
broke the spark
and uh blew a fuse i have to jump to
silliness
boy so on the way home i [ __ ] blew a
fuse on the way home and then we had to
ju we had to jump it on the solenoid
just to get it just to get it started so
me and my buddy would you think it was a
lemon at that point or what oh i knew it
was good bro when i heard that engine
rather that 91 uh seven point three like
i said make you hard son i don't know
my cousin's been dead for years dude
you'll see the soil on his grave
that's right you'll see it fluff a
little bro that uh that 7.3 is an iconic
engine wow and let me just tell you
right now
i don't care if you're four guys chevy
guy dodge guy i don't even care if you
like [ __ ]
the honda trucks i don't care you cannot
talk [ __ ] about a cummins diesel engine
and you cannot talk [ __ ] about a 7.3
engine
i think international harvester might
actually make the engine at one point
they did i did some research on it but
um the thing about what i've got on a 91
from from i think 91 to 94 they did the
idis and that's what i got okay now
here's why i like it this is why this
truck was made for me brother well first
off it was 3 800 bucks it's in my
[ __ ] price range you know that's what
i'm saying
price mitchell they got that
surprisingly the price is right mitchell
bro that would be a good story the price
is right yeah
you'd be so much better than bob barker
on that show man
if there's ever a price is right you're
the [ __ ] husband i've been
giving away damn i will meet on that
[ __ ] sure wouldn't even last episode
you'd be giving away everything
i get half them [ __ ] away up there
too dude that's right we got to get rid
of some of these [ __ ] over here man
so that the idi engine is different than
these modern power strokes uh power
stroke is uh they're both great engines
uh forward engines but this idi is
mechanical in nature so it doesn't have
as much computer
uh
parts and so
that's what i love about it i [ __ ]
cannot stand all this cheap electronic
[ __ ] and let me tell you
it it ruins everything and it is to the
level where it is a conspiracy if you
don't think that they're making these
cars to break at a certain point or
making it more expensive for certain
parts you're [ __ ] blind bro because
that's what the industry the cars from
the 90s with the manual transmissions
and the simple engines last longer and
are easier to fix
than these newer ones they're doing that
because they want you in the dealership
yeah and uh they don't like i got the
best mechanic in the [ __ ] world that
lives like right down the road from me
his name is paul underwood and uh let me
tell you what i guarantee you mr paul
could fix anything on that 7.3 idi right
you know and he could probably fix a
power stroke too but there's going to be
some com computer yeah something you
can't that's out of your control but
it's just like okay you're going to have
to order this cheap ass part from some
just to get the [ __ ] to work yeah and by
now they know how long you're going to
use a car it's just so many things
it's a conspiracy bro like it's it's
called uh if you want to look into it
it's called planned obsolescence it's
been going on really since the beginning
of time it's not a conspiracy bro but
like when it first started getting
popular there was one instance of it in
germany there was a uh people who made
t-shirts i believe maybe t-shirts or
jeans but they started using nylon well
bro
nobody they didn't have any return
customers because the [ __ ] t-shirts
and jeans was lasting damn forever just
like they sell a pair of jeans and you
never see that [ __ ] again so
they had to start making shitty jeans
but bro that's in every single
industry that there is and it's two
certain degrees but in the car industry
you see so much planned obsolescence
these pieces of [ __ ] especially nissans
with their cvt transmissions uh you know
because they have one going on
damn but um i wouldn't even comment but
here's it exactly well i beg to differ
on that one
let me tell you what them headlights for
example you get you one of these nissan
2006 uh maximus this is a planned
obsolescence that i'm talking about to
certain degrees okay you fix your you
break your headlight guess how much that
[ __ ] new one cost
probably 250 150 yeah damn bro it's a
[ __ ] headlight they can make that for
three dollars yeah you know what i'm
saying so they get you and they do that
with their transmissions they do what
they're in not this ford engine not this
7.3 idi it's a real engine made for real
farmers who really work for their real
money and don't want to spend it on no
fake [ __ ] you know and that truck is is
me personified
baby and uh the only thing i gotta do is
gotta add a little uh one of those uh
gooseneck balls on the back of it you
know that mounts right there in a truck
bed uh-uh oh for uh for pulling that
heavy weight
from cattle oh really and hey
so what you'll it's for it is for the
transmission now well it's it's um so
you can actually pull that weight if you
you know the
the balls that hang off the back like a
regular like on the you'll see up there
in that truck you see i got a little
two-inch ball i got a three-way right on
the back of it not the kind you like but
yeah the kind with uh you know
they come with three different uh
hitches on it yeah yeah yeah well that
sticks off the back of the truck okay
okay when you mount one of these uh
gooseneck or fifth wheel um hitches you
gotta do it from the inside from the
truck bed
and so that distributes to where all
that weight ain't on that it puts more
of it up front so your truck and more of
the weight goes to the trailer and so
now you can pull uh 32 000 pounds bro
like i'm i'm gonna be pulling some [ __ ]
you know damn wow yeah so i got to get
that i got to fix my brake lights i
gotta rig it up to where i'm not jumping
the solenoid every time i start it oh
he's got a little bit of ash on the
seats i could tell this dude he had a
swisher when i pulled out the little cup
holder thing he had a swisher in it
i'm like probably ain't even tripping i
just wish i was here for that one you
know what i'm saying
but bro it's so cool like it's an old
school manual
and by the way you don't ever see these
manuals that's how you know they're
they're trying to make these vehicles to
break now you can't even hardly find a
[ __ ] truck with a man i will never i
would never buy another vehicle that's
not a manual unless something crazy
happens and i get some good deal or
something you know but um you know this
thing is like you put it in the first
bro and like you don't even just let off
the clutch man like it's going to go
it's not going to die yeah you know it's
got so much power like i'm not even
touching the gas you just put it in
first knowing that it just creeps
yeah it is nice to get into something
that feels like it has a life of its own
bro it does man it's got two gas tanks
on it and you switch it but one of them
don't read so you just kind of like have
to
you are the gas gauge
that's fire dude
old school not even knowing how much gas
is so i just i just know it was meant
for me bro
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you